♪ ♪
>> Juan: WELCOME BACK, CAN
JOE BIDEN, THE DEMOCRATS
PRESUMPTIVE NOMINEE FOR
PRESIDENT BRING HIS PARTY
TOGETHER FOR THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION.
OF THE FORMER VP IS DOING HIS
BEST TOE WOO BERNIE SANDERS
SUPPORTERS NOW THAT SANDERS HAS
SUSPENDED HIS CAMPAIGN PAID WHAT
WE SEE NOW IS THAT BIDEN IS
COMING OUT WITH A PLAN TO EXPEND
MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY AND TO
FORGIVE STUDENT LOAN DEBTS, BOTH
IDEAS PUT TOGETHER BYSTANDERS.
BIDEN SAYS THAT HE WILL DO THESE
THINGS IF HE IS ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
AND A BETTER ACT QUICKLY,
BECAUSE A NEW POLL FROM FOX NEWS
SHOWS THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
TIED WITH BIDEN AT 42% SUPPORT
APIECE.
LET ME COME TO YOU AND ASK,
GIVEN WHAT JOE BIDEN IS DOING, A
LITTLE BIT OF A SURPRISE TO ME,
BECAUSE POLITICIANS AFTER THE
PRIMARIES, THEY USUALLY MOVE TO
THE CENTER, BUT NOW WE SEE
JOE BIDEN MOVING TO THE LEFT.
HOW DO YOU INTERPRET THIS?
>> Jesse: I THINK IT IS WEAK.
AND YOU ARE DEAD ON, JUAN.
THIS IS TOO LATE.
BERNIE BROSE WANT A REVOLUTION,
ANYTHING SHORT OF A REVOLUTION
IS NOT GOING TO BE GOOD ENOUGH
FOR THE BERNIE BURROUGHS.
YOU SAW BERNIE ON STAGE, ANYBODY
TO THE RIGHT OF BERNIE HE
BASICALLY SAID WAS A CAPITALIST
PIG THAT WAS BUSINESS AS USUAL.
SO I DON’T THINK IT WILL DO YOU
BIDEN ANY GOOD TO FLIRT WITH THE
BERNIE BROS OR MAKE AN OVERTURE.
HIS BASE IS CRACKED.
HE WILL LOSE 15 TO 20% OF THE
BERNIE BROS.
AND A FACT THAT A FOX NEWS POLL
HAS PRESIDENT TRUMP TIED WITH
THE JOE BIDEN THIS FAR OUT TO A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION IS VERY
GOOD NEWS FOR THE PRESIDENT.
>> Juan: GREG, IS THERE
ANYTHING, ANYTHING THAT
JOE BIDEN CAN DO TO REALLY PULL
IN THE BERNIE BROS.
BECAUSE THE HARD COURT
SUPPORTERS.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE NOT
NECESSARILY HARD-CORE ON THE
BERNIE SIDE.
BUT WHAT COULD JOE BIDEN DO TO
SAY TO THEM, JUMP ON THE
BANDWAGON?
>> Greg: HE SHOULD WEAR A
BERNIE MASK, BECAUSE THAT’S KIND
OF WHAT HE IS DOING RIGHT NOW.
IF I WERE TRUMP, I WOULD SAY,
JOE IS JUST BIDEN IN A BERNIE
MASK.
REMEMBER WHEN WE HAD LINES FOR
FOOD, UNEMPLOYMENT, THAT’S THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THAT’S HOW SOCIALISM LOOKS
PRETTY GOT A TASTE, AND THAT’S
WHAT YOU WILL GET.
BUT ANYWAY, BECAUSE IT IS YOUR
BIRTHDAY, JUAN, I HAVE A SPECIAL
TALKING POINT ESPECIALLY FOR YOU
YOU.
THE BIG PROBLEM WITH JOE IS THAT
HE COULD NOT PULL OFF A PRESSER
LIKE TODAY.
TRUMP’S BRAIN IS AGILE AND SWIFT
AND CAPABLE.
AND WHEN YOU WATCH THAT, YOU PUT
JOE IN THAT PLACE AND YOU KNOW
THAT HE GETS EASILY FRUSTRATED
OVER SIMPLE SENTENCES.
SO HERE’S MY TALKING POINT, THE
QUESTION ON EVERYONE’S MIND
RIGHT NOW IS COULD
PRESIDENT TRUMP BE THE MOST
CARING PRESIDENT WE HAVE EVER
HAD IN THE HISTORY OF THE
COUNTRY?
BECAUSE THE EVIDENCE IS CLEAR,
HE IS WILLING TO PUT ITS
ECONOMIC ACHIEVEMENTS IN
JEOPARDY TO SAVE LIVES.
HE IS WILLING TO BANKRUPT HIS
OWN BUSINESS TO SAVE LIVES.
HE IS WILLING TO LOSE REELECTION
TO SAVE LIVES, PUT THAT ON TOP
OF HIS REPULSION OVER MILITARY
INTERVENTION AND HIS DEEP DESIRE
TO GET TROOPS OUT OF HARM’S WAY,
THIS GUY MAKES FLORENCE
NIGHTINGALE LOOK LIKE LIZZIE
BORDEN.
THAT’S MY BIRTHDAY TALKING POINT
TO JUAN.
>> Jesse: WOW.
[LAUGHTER]
HAPPY BIRTHDAY, JUAN.
>> Juan: THAT WAS THE ICING ON
TOP OF THE CAKE.
TOO SWEET.
I CAN ONLY EAT SO MUCH.
>> Greg: I WROTE IT FOR YOU,
JUAN, I KNEW THAT YOU WOULD LOVE
IT.
>> Juan: IT IS SO RICH, YOU
KNOW?
SO, DANA, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE TALK ABOUT HERE IS THE
PRESIDENT HAS CLEARLY BEEN
TRYING TO FOAM AT THE FIGHTING,
THE INTERNAL DISSENSION AMONG
DEMOCRATS, BUT I THINK TO
MYSELF, IF YOU ARE ON THE
JOE BIDEN CAMP AND YOU SAY TO
THE BERNIE SANDERS SUPPORTERS,
WHO DO YOU WANT TO REPLACE
RUTH BADER GINSBURG?
WELL, THAT JUST SHOCK THEM AND
SAY, ALL RIGHT, I WAS JUST
PLAYING AROUND.
OF COURSE I WILL VOTE FOR
JOE BIDEN.
>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
NOT JUST THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF
AND THE DECIDER IN CHIEF, HE IS
THE INSTIGATOR IN CHIEF.
HE IS REALLY GOOD AT IT LIKE
JESSE WAS SAYING, HOW USED TO DO
AT THE LUNCH TABLE, GET PEOPLE
TO FIGHT.
IT’S GOOD TO GET YOUR ENEMIES
AND FIGHT AGAINST THEMSELVES.
IT’S REALLY GOOD.
BUT TO THE VICTOR SHOULD GO THE
SPOILS.
BUT THAT’S ONLY FOR A CONFIDENT
CONQUEROR.
AND JOE BIDEN IS A WEEK NOMINEE.
HE IS HOBBLED.
AND NOW HE IS IN THE MIDDLE OF
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THIS DURING
A PANDEMIC.
AND INSTEAD OF BEING VICTORIOUS
AND AS YOU SAID, MOVE TO THE
CENTER AND SAY, I CAN BE THE
PRESIDENT FOR ALL AMERICANS, HE
IS PUTTING OUT POLICY PROPOSALS
THAT PROBABLY WOULD HAVE HELPED
HIM IN NEW HAMPSHIRE PRIMARY,
NOT NOW.
AND I DON’T UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEIR STRATEGY IS.
MAYBE THEY WILL COME OUT ONE DAY
AND TRY TO TELL US.
>> Juan: EMILY, I THINK THE
STRATEGY IS EMERGING.
WOULD YOU GIVE THESE FOLKS TIME?
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THERE IS A
POLITICAL PROCESS TAKEN PLACE IN
WHICH BIDEN IS TRYING TO NOT
ONLY WOO SOME OF THE UNDER
SUPPORTERS, BUT WOO SANDERS
HIMSELF, IS THAT A FAIR
ASSESSMENT?
>> Emily: IT MIGHT BE.
AND I THINK THE QUESTION IS
WHETHER HE HAS ENOUGH TIME TO
WORK THIS MIRACLE.
I THINK SHORT OF VENTRILOQUISM,
THIS BALANCING ACT WILL NOT
WORK.
I DON’T THINK HE CAN HAVE IT
BOTH WAYS.
AND I MEAN THAT RIGHT NOW WE SEE
HIM CAPITULATING TO THE BERNIE
BROS.
TALKING ABOUT CLIMATE POLICY,
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY TUITION
FORGIVENESS, ALL OF THAT STUFF
THAT THEY LOVE, BUT AT THE SAME
TIME, HE CAN’T HAVE HIS CAKE AND
EAT IT TOO WITH THE INDEPENDENCE
AND THE MODERATES THAT HE NEEDS
TO ACTUALLY WIN THE GENERAL
ELECTION.
SO MOVING FORWARD, HE NEEDS TO
MAKE THAT CALL AS TO WHAT WHAT
ACTUALLY BENEFIT HIM.
AT THE END OF THE DAY AS JESSE
POINTED OUT, THOSE BERNIE BROS
CARE ABOUT AUTHENTICITY.
IF HE CHOOSES ANOTHER
ESTABLISHMENT VP CANDIDATE AND
THINGS BY TALKING THAT TALKIE